if we go back perhaps three billion
years and take a look at Mars Mars was a
very different planet it had an
extensive atmosphere and in fact it had
what we believe was a huge ocean perhaps
as large as two-thirds of the northern
hemisphere and that ocean may have been
as much as a mile deep so Mars indeed
three billion years ago had extensive
water resources but something happened
mar suffered a major climate change and
lost its surface water today we're
revolutionizing our understanding of
this planet our Rovers are finding that
there's a lot more humidity in the air
than we ever imagined as we ingest the
soils they're moist they're hydrated
full of water these discoveries are very
important but they were only part of the
hydrological cycle on Mars that we're
just now beginning to understand what
we're going to announce today is that
Mars is not the dry arid planet that we
thought of in the past today we're going
to announce that under certain
circumstances liquid water has been
found on Mars